you know in terms of the trade talks i
think anytime you play professional
sports there's always a possibility of
something happen right well i think
there's a lot of confusion and everybody
was saying that i requested a trade
and that wasn't true so we made it clear
that i did not request a trade i did not
request a trade
i've always wanted to play here well i
think there's a lot of confusion
because the rowdy is is that i forget i
think i was in the bahamas or somewhere
and everybody was saying that i
requested a trade
and that wasn't true so we made it clear
that i did not request a trade and then
there was teams being flown around that
i was going to go to those teams this
and that and so you know i think that
you know when you look back at it you
know it's it's part of
uh i don't know i think it's part of it
um unfortunately with the comments you
made about the offensive line and being
frustrated with getting hit some people
have taken that as maybe criticism of
the offensive line did you mean that as
sort of a direct criticism of the
offensive line in general not not at all
about the offensive line i think that i
also mentioned you know i mentioned that
you know the reality is that i can do
better too
that was russell wilson from last
thursday
miles simmons and i
talked about it on friday look he didn't
request a trade chris because he didn't
have to i mean yes it wasn't until his
encounter with santa claus that ralphie
officially requested a red rider carbine
action range model air rifle with a
compass in the stock and this thing that
tells time he didn't have to he made it
known that that's what he wanted we all
know he wanted to be traded he never had
to show up at pete carroll's door and
bang on and say i demand that you trade
me his agent came out and said my client
doesn't want to be traded but if he were
to be traded he would accept trades to
the bears saints cowboys and or raiders
so i i i look
i didn't have a big problem with it
because i knew he had to do it at some
point he's all about
going out and trying to make chicken
salad and he's stuck in a place where he
hasn't been satisfied in recent years
he's gonna make the best of it because
this is one more crack
at building the legacy he wants to build
he's got one super bowl win in nine
seasons just like aaron rodgers with one
and patrick mahomes with one he's gonna
do everything he can to get it to number
two this year
and after this year
that's when
it all gets dusted off again and he
won't request a trade but it'll be
obvious that he would love to have a
trade to a new team yeah well i mean you
know
gosh there's so many things i mean first
off he's smart enough to know like at
that time he didn't
he did not say the exact words of i
request a trade or anything like that he
sent out every signal in the world to
like what you're saying to say that i
mean come on that it's insane it's a
little crazy he's gotten away with it to
the degree of what he got away with you
know it tells you about the charm he has
really come on nobody no starting
quarterbacks really throwing their team
under the bus quite to the capacity with
russell wilson did after the season he
threw everybody under the bus and he
grins and smiles and he talks good and
his eyes move everywhere in the press
conference because he doesn't want to be
any tells or anything like that but like
come on that's what he did i mean that
he went scorched earth as far as a
starting quarterback is concerned uh on
his own franchise kind of let it be
known of all the issues that he didn't
like about the football team yes
and obviously i mean we know the bears
went all in on trading for russell
wilson and the seattle seahawks like so
they didn't go all in because they went
well this is just rumors and florio and
sims are talking about it so let's just
call them and put up a trade offer but
it's not really real like come on get
the hell out of here they knew that
russell wilson
wanted out and was willing to go to
chicago they've talked to his agent they
put a trade package together come on
like this bullcrap so he could say
whatever he wants and blah blah blah
blah blah blah but we know that he was
forcing the issue this offseason to a
degree
and yes didn't happen so now the
toothpaste is back in the toothpaste
holder and he'll make like you said the
best out of the situation for right now
but yeah i expect some of the same
comments when the season's over next
year and that's the difference between
him and aaron rodgers yeah now rogers
has been dealing with his frustration
and disrespect
longer than wilson and it's not like the
seahawks have gone out and drafted
wilson's potential replacement but
wilson recognizes
i want another super bowl
and staying away from ota is or
mandatory mini camp does not help me get
there there's a certain point where i
have to swallow my pride and i have to
be all in because this is my only shot
yeah it's either play for the seahawks
or not play i want to play yeah i'd like
to play for someone else i'd like to
play for an offense that runs through me
i'd like to play for an offensive
coordinator who's a little more diverse
in the formations and the efforts to
stay ahead of the defense and and i'd
rather not have a head coach who if he
gets freaked out by a couple of bad
games all of a sudden wants to go back
to meat and potatoes and and not do
anything imaginative that allows me to
show what i can do
he'd prefer all those things but he's
stuck where he is and so he's there he's
engaged he's going to say all the right
things because the goal is get to the
super bowl and win it and if they do
great if they don't if they don't make
it they haven't been to the nfc
championship since 2014
if they don't get back to at least the
game to get to the super bowl i fully
expect
all this to be back front and center
next year and it could be not just aaron
rodgers being traded after the season
but rogers and wilson and maybe deshawn
watts now what do you think though like
if they get back to the divisional
playoff game but it has a different look
this year right like
russell wilson the offense are explosive
he's got great numbers
things like that everything looks on the
up and up
like i don't know i'm
that's one scenario i wonder what he
would do there because like like to what
you're saying
you know first off you know there's
worse places to be stuck
and
you do have dk metcalf and tyler lockett
it's we talked about last week it's one
of the better duos in football i mean
it's up there towards the top of the
league they could those guys are
difference makers
so yeah it i just it's going to be
interesting this year because i do think
they're gonna have
more of a schematical advantage on the
offensive side of the ball with the new
offense we heard the comments last week
right from russell wilson where he was
like the offense is super complicated
yeah because he's doing stuff he's never
done he doesn't know what he doesn't
know so this is going to be fun to see
what what what shane waldron can add
and that's the key the key to this is
shane waldrop
what will he do to make the offense less
predictable what will he do to avoid
what we saw last year when it was let
ross cook until
the defenses could figure out the recipe
and they didn't counter it effectively
and that's what freaked out pete carroll
can waldron do enough
wire to wire week one through week 18
and into the post season to make russ
say damn they're they're finally doing
what i've wanted the offense is running
through me and it's great and it works
and that's going to be the tension
that's going to be yeah the the focal
point right will pete carroll allow
shane waldron
to uh to go out and take over and and
you know what i don't want to get too
far ahead of myself here
now i'm i'm going to save her for
another day i'm not going to say well
that is just not even that's not even
fair you can't do that that's not it's
not allowed that's like against
code
okay let's say the offense ends up being
spectacular right and we start hearing
shane waldron
as a potential head coach you know
somewhere else yeah at what point
at what point come with me russ for the
seahawks no no at what point does
ownership of the seahawks say it's time
for pete to go oh i know they just
signed him to an extension uh but if but
if you're faced with waldron and wilson
versus pete and whoever i'm just i i'm
not i'm just
i'm just
the the dominoes can fall in all sorts
of crazy ways and we all we know and
this is one of the problems of having a
defensive head coach
if you have a great offense you're going
to lose your coordinator you have to go
find another one and then you have a
great offense again you're going to lose
that one and he's going to go be a head
coach
and uh if if it works with waldron and
russ to the point where waldron becomes
a head coach yeah then maybe it's russ
goes with waldron
or maybe it's waldron becomes the head
coach of the seattle seahawks i guess we
just have to be keeping an eye on all
that that's that's what i wasn't gonna
say it officially haven't said yeah well
it's a it's it's not a crazy thought i i
mean it it's not um i don't think we're
there yet i don't at least just with the
seattle seahawks pete carroll he's too
damn special still that's all right too
if and he falls into the mike tomlin
category where if the seahawks would
decide it's time to move on carol's
gonna have a job by the end of the day a
hundred percent have a job by lunchtime
also like one of those things to where i
think it's too it's like you know
pete carroll's got away with people and
guys too where i think you know somebody
else goes up there they may be like whoa
there's a few more characters and
personalities and things going on here
than i thought that's where pete's
special that way so uh i mean i hear
what you're saying but i i don't think
we're there yet it but
man waldron sets the world on fire and
russ sets the world on fire on that
offensive side of the ball yeah it could
be interesting to see what happens up
there in seattle
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports